et si la tenue d'un second tour ne
concerne que 14% des communes la plupart
des grandes villes y figurent qui dit
grande ville dix plus grands risques
sanitaires alors question faut-il
organiser le second tour des municipales
au mois de juin c'est l'objet de notre
face à face ce soir et pour en débattre
nous sommes en direct avec eric kramer
conseiller municipal à trilport en seine
et marne candidat sans étiquette battu
de peu au premier tour signataires
également des tribunes dans le figaro
qui appelle à rejouer les deux tours
dans leur ensemble
à ses côtés maïder arostéguy candidate
les républicains à la mairie de biarritz
arrivé en tête avec 31% des voix au
second tour qui souhaitent le scrutin en
juin un bonsoir à tous les deux merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
maïder arostéguy vous on disait vous
êtes conseillère municipale arrivée en
tête au premier tour à biarritz on
imagine qu'il est effectivement logique
est plus aisé pour vous de souhaiter se
la tenue de ce premier tour en juin
alors en dehors de la question que ce
soit aisé ou pas on se retrouve
aujourd'hui en tout cas pour le
territoire que je connais qui est le
mien qui est biarritz avec un maire
sortant qui est arrivé en cinquième
position à 12 et demi pour cent et qui
vous le comprenez bien est dans une
position tout à fait un comporte un
confortable pour gérer autre chose que
les affaires courantes
beaucoup de maires n'ont pas été
forcément réélu du premier coup et on se
retrouve aujourd'hui avec des exécutifs
qu'ils soient municipaux et surtout
communautaire la ville de biarritz fait
partie de la deuxième plus grande
agglomération de france nous sommes à
regroupement de 158 communes le pci pays
basque et cet exécutif communautaire qui
gère les grandes décisions que sont les
décisions relatifs à la mobilité la
gestion des déchets
la gestion des eaux de baignade
également très importante pour notre
territoire
eh bien ces exécutifs aujourd'hui sont à
l'arrêt et lorsqu'on sait qu'en plus en
france plus de 70 % de l'investissement
public est porté par les collectivités
territoriales
il est important et urgent que nous
sortions de cette paralysie et que nous
puissions prendre des décisions et agir
eric la mer vous comprenez cet
argumentaire maïder arostéguy est arrivé
en tête donc effectivement c'est logique
peut-être qu'elle souhaite
ce deuxième tour en juin mais vous
comprenez tout de même ses arguments
tout simplement de mettre enfin en
marche ce conseil qu'on a commencé à
élire et de ne pas laisser passer trop
de temps pour des raisons logiques de
fonctionnement
oui alors effectivement tout à fait
comprendre la réaction de madame et qui
est en ballottage favorable
là parce que j'ai pu comprendre sauf que
on nous sommes dans une crise sans
précédent de sanitaires difficiles dans
nos communes moi je le vois je le vois
depuis le 15 mars ont fait la démocratie
aujourd'hui c'est un fiasco total est en
train de se produire dans notre pays le
gouvernement
comment dirais-je le gouvernement traîne
7,7
ces élections municipales comme un
boulet 15 mars alors qu'il aurait mieux
valu annuler tous déjà bien avant à
partir du moment où c'est qu'il ya eu
des signes significatifs de concernant
concernant l'annulation du virus sur
notre sur notre territoire ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui s'adaptent du mois de
janvier
donc à partir de ce moment les
intellectuels les deux problèmes qu'on a
aujourd'hui
pour l'heure le 28 juin si c'est la
dalle qui est retenue par le
gouvernement
on a la même sur le problème le problème
est comment les gens vont pouvoir faire
campagne
comment les gens vont pouvoir faire
campagne on a une équipe qui sont déjà
en place la les maires ils sont qui sont
encore élus puisqu'ils ont été
prolongées ils se retrouvent
avec à gérer cette crise qui d'ailleurs
pour certains jouent un petit peu avec
la distribution de masse des pros faire
campagne sur leur commune est totalement
d'ailleurs illégale parce que c'était
pendant toute la période de confinement
vous avez des gens qui font qu'ils font
qui n'ont pas pu faire campagne puisque
il soit resté confiné donc bien un
problème démocratique ce niveau là et
puis le problème c'est que on veut pas
on ne peut pas faire et comme on appelle
ça des réunions publiques
on peut pas faire des cafés thés cafés
public on peut pas faire des réunions
publiques serait ce qu'un politique on
peut même pas le faire parce qu'ils ont
peut pas se réunira pardonnez moi on a
compris le message on va justement
écoutez la réaction du président de
l'assemblée nationale ce matin richard
ferrand qui qui rejoint votre avis avant
de faire réagir maïder arostéguy écouter
la démocratie ce n'est pas que le vote
la démocratie c'est des campagnes qui
permettent d'expliquer ce que l'on veut
faire ou ne pas faire dans une commune
donc je m'interroge sur le fait de
savoir s'il est raisonnable de faire ça
si vite
maider arosteguy c'est vrai que ça pose
un problème de démocratie comme l'a très
bien expliqué eric kramer pas vraiment
de deux campagnes on ne peut pas aller
au contact des gens qu'est ce que vous
répondez à cet argumentaire
alors il me semble qu'on a perdu de vue
ce qu'est cette élection on est sur un
deuxième tour je vous rappelle qu'on a
deux jours entre le résultat du dimanche
soir jusqu'au mardi soir 18h dans un
temps traditionnels et donc il reste
trois petits jours pour faire campagne
puisque la campagne s'arrête le vendredi
soir donc c'est vrai qu'on va être privé
de ses réunions qu'elles soient
publiques ou qu'elles soient privées
enfin que je sache on est dans la phase
1 du déconfinement on espère que s'il
n'y a pas de 2,2 rebonds de l'épidémie
nous pourrons être totalement déconfit
nez avec les bars les restaurants
réouvert
et donc il ne sera pas interdit d'être
au contact des citoyens et de faire
campagne comme on le fait
traditionnellement sur les marchés dans
la rue dans les quartiers
et s'il faut qu'on le fasse masqué
aujourd'hui les citoyens sont habitués à
nous voir avec le port du masque
donc moi ça ne me paraît pas être une
difficulté majeure
on s'adaptera il me semble quand même ça
a été avérés depuis le premier tour des
municipales il ya eu des mères décédées
qui ont attrapé ce coronavirus pendant
la campagne mais aussi lors du premier
tour ça a été le cas de ses soeurs on
imagine que c'est une responsabilité
immense que prend edouard philippe avec
les chefs de partis autour d'eux mêmes
alors par rapport à ça on a déjà des
difficultés à tester aujourd'hui on ne
teste pas on ne sait pas véritablement
si on a pu avoir le coc vide ou pas moi
les personnes qui me disent on a attrapé
le coc vide le jour des élections ça
veut dire ce sont des personnes qui
quinze jours avant sont restées chez
elles confinent et sans voir personne
n'ont pas pris en transports en commun
n'ont pas fait leurs courses ne sont pas
et dans une boulangerie
c'est impossible de dire que on a
attrapé le coc vide le jour des
élections
quant aux risques il faut bien sûr être
d'une prudence extrême et c'est le
conseil scientifique qui vient de
remettre son rapport hier qui a donné le
feu vert à la condition bien sûr que
deux semaines avant on soit en capacité
d'y aller moi je fais confiance au
premier ministre pour ne pas mettre la
vie des français en danger mais je vous
rappelle que théoriquement si tout va
bien le 28 juin la vie quasi normale de
la france aura repris avec notamment
l'ouverture des bars et des restaurants
éric kraemer notre réponse au pas ma
réponse elle est simple c'est que
effectivement on peut pas juger le
dimanche 15 mars et jean rattraper les
connaît ils ont quand même fait campagne
juste avant et il n'y a pas que le jour
de la l'élection que les gens à hugo dit
le problème c'est que il ya eu quand
même quelques jours auparavant
mais moi je me souviens avoir hésité
longuement savoir si je
la réunion publique donc oui les gens
les gens l'eau chauffée certainement ce
jour là comme avant certainement aussi
mais il va y avoir quand même un
problème c'est que les gens qui n'ont
pas été votées déjà le 15 mars n'ira
n'iront pas plus côté le bas puis de la
cuisine moi et ceux qui déjà mal que
j'ai vu tant nous sommes heureux c'est
des gens qui allaient voter la peur au
ventre
donc les gens ces gens-là et ben ils
font pas la bêtise deux fois avec les
gens qui sont décédés avec les gens qui
ont été malades savez moi je prédis que
il va y avoir une abstention encore sur
ce ce jour là et on va se retrouver on
va se retrouver avec un déni de
démocratie puisque la démocratie c'est
effectivement tout le monde puisse aller
voter dans les bonnes conditions
or aujourd'hui on en est pas en mesure
de tenir de tenir ces capteurs
ces câbles maïder arostéguy ça pose
aussi le problème de ce qu'on appelle
constitutionnellement l'un c'est
l'insincérité du scrutin beaucoup de
maires l'ont dénoncé avec une
participation même pour certains qui ont
été élus dès le premier tour
une participation très faible est ce que
ça ne pose pas encore une fois
effectivement un problème de démocratie
la participation a été moins moins
importante que dans les scrutins passés
je ne sais pas si le scrutin est
insincère je peux comprendre que ceux
qui sont en ballottage défavorable qui
ont perdu pensent que le scrutin est
insincère
en ce qui concerne notre territoire le
résultat est plutôt conformes aux
sondages d'opinion qui ont été réalisés
au mois de janvier avec évidemment
quelques nuances
je dirais que le deuxième tour devrait
devrait confirmer
on est sur une région dans lequel nous
avons beaucoup de personnes âgées qui
étaient donc les plus les celles qui ont
eu le plus peur d'aller voter elles sont
quand même allés voter on a vu quand
même des défis l'importante de de
personnes ces gens là ont fait l'effort
d'aller voter
moi je ne voudrais pas que sous prétexte
d'un sincérité
comme nous allons avoir après la crise
sanitaire une crise économique et une
crise sociale à la rentrée dont
d'ailleurs le gouvernement redoute
qu'elle soit violente
je ne voudrais pas qu'on crée les
conditions d'une crise démocratique et
que les gens aient l'impression qu'on va
leur voler cette élection avec les
français sont très attachés à l'élection
du maire c'est vraiment le mandat de la
proximité on dit souvent qu'on est à
portée de main et moi tous les jours
depuis que je ressors après après le
confinement même masquer les gens me
disent alors quand est-ce qu'on vote
quand est ce qu est le deuxième tour
donc en ce qui concerne mon territoire
je peux témoigner avec la plus grande
sincérité d'une attente est d'un intérêt
des citoyens biarrots en tout cas pour
que cette élection touche à sa fin merci
à tous les deux éric kraemer maïder
arostéguy d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france pour débattre de ce
second tour des municipales
l'hypothèse donc est relancé pour une
tenue fin juin merci à vous deux